[ __ ] you know frozen frozen frozen why
I'm not even wrapped
where are the burgers I mean it just
doesn't look anything like a burger time
when it's processed like that and
stabbed impress you can just tell Wow
Bret come with me yeah how's the
fettuccine not the best I'm sorry
um burgers a Burger cooked here locally
would you expect that to be frozen or
fresh the burger is not frozen
it's the patties and everything come in
frozen when you thought out is that like
Mara people before it out so it's not
the frozen that it comes in frozen yeah
you thought out and that to the your
customers it's not frozen burger well
stay there let me just show you how are
you
[Music]
I'm waiting for him to come back he's
gonna ream me on something oh boy here
we go
mm-hmm so there's your burgers is it
frozen
thank you well you husband said it
wasn't know what I mean
no it's it's frozen of course I never
said that it wasn't it we thought out
here it comes in frozen yeah it's still
a frozen burger there's no such thing as
a fresh burger at least at least here in
eastern Washington have you seen any of
this stuff going on here whichever the
idea what's going on what's this
pre-cooked bacon trickle from when it's
dated think they do it every day just
about no they don't
when was that cause that's not today
they did honestly let's see what it says
10:31 we're in November the 6th now this
is insane look at that and there don't
you drain that or it just sits there in
his blood
I mean here that's all freezer
is that some noise that's the fan
Oh Karen you've got no idea that this is
going on like this
what is that in there that's dishwater
no as French by the into the fries why
is the water so dirty nobody need change
it sorry nobody didn't changes her but
you're cooking fries from there tonight
in that water I saw them fill up the
fryer twice this sucks
where'd you get the ham from she bought
it at the store
holy crap it's a spiral cut they cut it
and put it in here and then use it for
side of ham for breakfast
what was last time this was cleaned last
year when I clean this Chef last year
when we clean the oven we're in November
last year yes sir I asked Karen Sakai we
need to shut down to me we got it we got
to do Maitlis look at the mess
why'd you let it go like this I didn't
know that they were doing things that
were not turned that perm no but listen
to me job this stuff bullshitting the
guy
okay let's tell the truth here okay I
asked for four new equipment
I can't get no new equipment why not
I've been in for four years I've been
answered for new equipment I can't work
with this [ __ ] here look look at that
[ __ ] test why is this Wow Oh
look at them the waters gone slimy and
you come in here once a week yeah what
is that
[Music]
oh boy
okay how what is that
pina colada pina colada
why it's like that I have no idea it's
best that it is office bubbling
[Music]
oh man that's terrible
[ __ ] trash please trash James you trash
please now Pina Colada right down the
drain by the bucketload in the walk-in
fridge I mean who in the hell operates
like this
Gordon this is Chef Ben's job is the
Executive Chef is the Executive Chef and
you've made him that Executive Chef
right sure I did
how'd you feel now what's that tuna
burger that's from the burger yes it is
oh my god seriously bacon it's gone it's
off fresh produce on top of all produce
moldy and this one ribeye ribeye
defrosting what is this those are the
smoked grilled chicken wings before they
go onto the char grill Oh God and what
is in this one you're kidding me
so underneath in that buckets was cook
brother cooked the chicken and on top of
it is what it's rough raw chicken on top
of cooked chicken I had them for lunch I
am at a [ __ ] loss
you're the best way out of this it's
just shut the place down what a mess
wheels are stuck he was just sliding on
the [ __ ] grease it's gross
Brenda you got two seconds sure just
stand behind there with him please stand
behind there I'm I'm what is this
Maceo you guys just clean this and this
from today I don't even know what's back
there for render watts when was that
cleaned it's just a few days ago they
got spilled everything there come in
I know handled ha
that is not from yesterday that is not
from yesterday what's that up there
what's your eyes what's your eyes who
cleans it [ __ ] who is it
there's that many earth no one clean
since you've been here no one's cleaned
I appreciate your honesty Miranda yes
since he's been here he's never cleaned
it this place is disgusting
and this
Roberta I don't come and do this joke I
trust them that they would keep you guys
clean the floor the other day didn't you
we cleaned the line the other day we
spooked alarm you said you fights to
power I never said it and if you're just
trying to make excuses yes you are are
you embarrassed
very at least you taught the [ __ ]
truth the owners in denial that has been
pulled out for [ __ ] months there was
a board out